wenn Sie sich anschauen was da wirklich
passiert also sie haben eine Akte die
besteht aus hunderten vielleicht
tausenden sein
diese Akte wird von eine Zeitung oder
eine Zeitschrift ein Magazin ein Podcast
zusammengeschmolzen auf fünf Seiten was
schon
eine Meisterleistung ist wenn dadurch
nichts verloren geht ja dann wird diese
Geschichte veröffentlicht
in irgendeinem Medium eine Minute später
eine Minute später hat jeder auf Twitter
eine Meinung er war es er war es nicht
sie hat gelogen sie sagt die Wahrheit
es findet sonst nichts mehr statt es ist
sozusagen nur noch ein ein Reiz ich lese
die Geschichte oft nur noch die
Überschrift diese Geschichte und habe
dazu eine Meinung ja
das ist das sogenannte das ist das
sogenannte limbische System ja das haben
wir mit den Schimpansen gemeinsam ja
also da findet nicht statt außer Emotion
und und der präfrontale Cortex wo
sozusagen
wo wir anfangen nachzudenken dass eine
ruhige Abwägung und so weiter das findet
nicht mehr statt und diese Meinung wird
rausgebrüllt ja wirklich rausgebrüllt
was anderes ist das nicht und und
dadurch kommt etwas Zustand wir haben
das gesehen bei bei Johnny Depp und am
behört ja gesehen
besonders deutlich weil es so Amerika
wirklich in zwei Lage geteilt hat und
keiner von uns ist in der Lage das
überhaupt zu verstehen über was dort
geredet wird das ist wirklich sehr sehr
sehr komplex ja
die Frage ist jetzt haben wir das
beschrieben das weiß eigentlich jeder
die Frage ist was machen wir dagegen wie
kommen wir dagegen an und ich würde
einen Vorschlag machen wir haben im
Moment im
[Musik]
deutschen Recht zwei Möglichkeiten wie
jemand der geschädigt worden ist sich
gegen diese Schädigung wehren kann wir
haben Schadensersatz und wir haben
Schmerzensgeld
Schadensersatz ist also für dass der
erlittene Schaden wieder ausgeglichen
wird das ist unendlich kompliziert und
er gibt nie viel Geld und wir haben
Schmerzensgeld der das in Deutschland
traditionell sehr niedrig ist
warum machen wir nicht eine dritte
Genugtuung und zwar ein Strafgeld wie
ist das in Amerika beispielsweise gibt
in ein bisschen andere Farben aber das
könnte man hier machen wenn jemand in
seinem Ansehen durch ein solchen Text in
einer Zeitung
geschädigt wird schwer geschädigt wird
und sich später herausstellt dass diese
Schädigung zu Unrecht erfolgt ist und
der die Zeitung oder wer auch immer das
nicht beweisen kann dann muss die
Zeitung eine Million Summe bezahlen kann
der Richter festlegen was würde
passieren es würden nicht weniger Texte
veröffentlicht sondern die Texte die
veröffentlicht werden würden sehr viel
genauer geprüft werden weil die Zeitung
Angst haben müsste ich muss Millionen
bezahlen wenn ich jetzt etwas
veröffentliche was ich nicht beweisen
kann im Moment ist es so dass alles was
zwischen
der Veröffentlichung und dem Schaden der
der Eintritt steht ist die Zeitung die
sich nach
ordentlich verhalten will nach nach den
Regeln
aber sie hätten trotzdem die Zeitung und
die Zeitung würde nur etwas
veröffentlichen wo indem sie sich sicher
sein könnte dieses sozialen Medien
großen Zeitungen auf den großen
Plattformen veröffentlicht wird
triggeren spätesten konzentrieren aber
wir hätten das ja auch nicht es hilft ja
nicht obwohl die dargegangen genau
dieses System haben aber es ist die
einzige Möglichkeit die wir haben sie
schauen Sie mal die diese die die
Zeitung versuchen es ja so ordentlich
wie möglich zu machen daran besteht ja
kein Zweifel wenn Sie sich anschauen wie
die Recherchen beispielsweise der Zeit
sind bei dem verstorbenen Regisseur wie
viele Frauen die gehört haben wie
ordentlich sieht das aufgeschrieben
haben das überhaupt nichts dran
auszusetzen aber wenn es dann trotzdem
nicht reicht und wenn es eine
Unsicherheit gibt dann darf es halt
nicht veröffentlicht werden und das
finde ich schon das wäre schon ein
großer Schritt in die Richtung
dass man vorsichtiger aber bei der
Mensch entschuldigung wenn ich das nur
sagen der Mensch den es betrifft
beispielsweise sie haben gerade gesagt
Kevin Spacey Luke mocket die sind
vernichtet Kachelmann bis heute obwohl
sich rausgestellt hat dass es falsch
Johnny Depp als auch Kevin Spacey haben
ja das Problem dass sie in den
Vereinigten Staaten keine Verträge mehr
kriegen also und Sie haben ja damage das
haben sie ja in den Vereinigten Staaten
also ich glaube das löst das Problem
nicht wirklich also und dass das jetzt
unsere Zeitung ich hätte er denn
Bedenken aber da kann Frau dunzieren
ihren eigenen Anwalt spielen ich hatte
er bedenken dass das jetzt den
Journalismus noch stärker einschränken
würde als es ohnehin schon der Fall ist
also da wäre ich hätte das ist wirklich
helfen sagte gerade als ich die Namen
gerade eben aufgezählt habe sagte kann
man nicht miteinander vergleichen habe
ich auch nicht getan sind alles ganz
verschiedene Fälle wie schauen sie da
drauf gibt ja den Begriff der
sogenannten Verdachtsberichterstattung
ist zum Beispiel der Fall Tillmann
rammstein ist das rechtfertigt das so zu
berichten bevor man wirklich weiß
welcher Ermittlungen laufen bevor man
wirklich wasserdichte Beweise hat ist
das nach ihrer Auffassung in Ordnung so
oder müssten wir da vorsichtiger sein
Luke mockrid ist ein anderes Beispiel
dafür ich kann mich nur auf das Beziehen
in welchen Zeitungen ich das gelesen
habe die ich immer für seriös und total
verlässlich halte und wenn eine
süddeutsche Zeitung eine große Seite 3
über die Schilderung der Frau und Frauen
macht die sagen dass sie eben gecastet
wurden um nach einem Konzert von
Rammstein
Backstage oder zu irgendeinen Raum zu
gehen mit KO-Tropfen beträufelt wurden
und eine Frau wird zitiert ich glaube
auch alles eine stattlich und alles da
abgewogen dass sie gesagt hat sie hatte
sie ist aufgewacht und hat gedacht sie
sie sei zerrissen innerlich dann
ich glaube erstmal diesen Medium weil
ich es seit 30 daran lese und weil ich
da noch keine gegenteilige
Meldung gehört habe dass die nicht
seriös sein wenn ich ich bin etwas
zusammengezogen Herr von Schirach als
sie Mito genannt haben metoo hat so viel
bewegt es hat so viel Frauen
die die Sicherheit gegeben ihr könnt
etwas sagen ihr könnt euch wehren Till
Lindemann ist der nächste Fall dass das
fiel mir nicht schwer zu glauben muss
ich sagen weil wenn ich die Texte von
Rammstein lese wird mir ziemlich
schlecht und da glaube ich erst mal
dass sich das im wirklichen Leben ein
bisschen weiterspielt weiter zeigt und
ein aktuellen Fall nur um das ist ganz
ganz klein dagegen aber wenn ein
spanischer
fußballpräsident eine spanische
fußball-weltmeisterin
packt und auf den Mund küsst und der
und Karl-Heinz Rummenigge vom FC Bayern
sagt
ein Hüte mit Verlaub das ist doch wohl
okay dann wissen wir was noch absolut im
Argen liegt und ich kann ihren Punkt
verstehen aber me too dafür zu nehmen um
das zu unterfüttern ist für mich ganz
schwieriges Beispiel weil es auf der
anderen Seite mit einer Macht und einer
Unverschämtheit und einer
Übergriffigkeit von bestimmten Männern
gebrochen hat was für für Frauen einfach
wahnsinnig wichtig war und ich hatte so
gehofft dass mir tut dazu geführt hat
dass Männer vorsichtiger werden und auf
Abstand bleiben und wenn man jetzt sowas
wieder sieht wie das da mit den
Fußballerinnen passiert ist und wie das
hier
dann kommentiert wird dann in dem Fall
gab es auch ein deutliches
gesellschaftliches Klima das sagt das
geht so nicht also dass man
sowas verändert als das das findet auch
kein normal gescheiter Mensch irgend
der kann das mal so raushauen und ja da
kriegt er dann auch die entsprechende
Reaktion darauf
ist ja auch nicht geworden bei der Sorte
Mann und deswegen noch mal auf den so ja
deswegen glaube ich eben bei dieser
sollte man wird wahrscheinlich immer so
bleiben ja und in diesem Fall weil sie
nimmt man Ansprachen
darf ich vielleicht zunächst mal kurz
darauf eingehen
ich habe nicht über me too in diesem
Sinn gesprochen ich habe und und metoo
ist dafür übrigens ein sehr gutes
Beispiel was die Presse tun kann
den Fall Winston
hätte ja jeder jederzeit veröffentlichen
gehören ohne in irgendeine Situation zu
kommen das in eine
strafgelzahlung droht und und es ist ja
absolut wunderbar und großartig und
nicht von der Presse gesteuert gewesen
übrigens wie metho angefangen hat
sondern das war ja tatsächlich mal eines
der wenigen positiven Beispiele die aus
den sozialen Medien kam wo die wo Frauen
sich unter diesem Hashtags feiern
Hashtag me too angefangen haben über
diese Leute zu äußern da ging ist doch
überhaupt nichts einzuwenden es geht um
einen anderen Punkt und zwar im ganz
anderen
es geht darum dass etwas nur dann und
das ist ein Gebot der Fairness meines
Erachtens nur dann veröffentlicht werden
darf
wenn sich derjenige der das
veröffentlicht vollkommen sicher ist und
auch klar darüber sein muss ich muss es
unter Umständen beweisen sonst darf ich
nicht verlieren
verdachtsbericht Erstattung darf es
jederzeit geben es darf auch jeden Zeit
eine Berichterstattung geben dass dort
junge Frauen von diese also bei bei
Lindemann dass die angeworben worden
sind so wie ich das gehört habe um
Backstage mit denen zu feiern oder in
sexuelle
zur Verfügung zu stellen egal ob es
freiwillig war ja das kann jederzeit
berichtet werden es geht in dem Fall
beispielsweise um die KO-Tropfen und
wenn sie die das verfolgt haben was da
jetzt passiert ist anscheinend ist
sozusagen wie ich es verstanden habe
aber ganz sicher bin ich mir auch nicht
dass die Kanzlei die Lindemann vertritt
inzwischen jedes Verfahren gewonnen hat
und das gibt einem dann schon zu denken
also
wie können wir es machen es ist ja nur
ein Vorschlag mit dem Strafgeld aber wie
wie können ja wenn die Frauen sagt ich
habe getroffen bekommen und jetzt sind
wir aber an dem entscheidenden Punkt
sie haben eine Frau oder Sie haben eine
ein Sachverhalt den sie nicht beweisen
aber dass der Mensch gegen den Sie da
schreiben
am Schluss am Boden ist und hingerichtet
ist das ist doch klar aber erstmal ist
die Frau am Boden und hingerichtet oder
nicht das können sie nicht beweisen sie
wissen nicht ob das was die Frau ihnen
sagt überhaupt richtig ist ich finde nur
der der Punkt muss sein
dass wir ein fairen Umgang auch an
diesen Stellen miteinander haben dass
wir nur etwas berichten von dem wir auch
sicher sind und dass wir es beweisen
können nur das ist mein Vorschlag und
eine
Verdachtsberichterstattung um Himmels
willen die muss es geben wir haben alle
verloren wenn die Presse keine Gedanken
weil wir beide dann Medien Vertreter
sind an dem Punkt aber wir müssen schon
ehrlich machen wir beide wissen das auch
ähm es wäre natürlich Abos verkauft über
genau solche Geschichten und je größer
der Name je größer die Fallhöhe desto
mehr Abos werden verkauft ich kenne auch
solche Äußerungen ich will das jetzt
in der Form nicht beitreten aber ich
könnte ihn sogar Zahlen sagen ich könnte
Ihnen ganz konkret Beispiele nennen von
Magazinen die sagen pass auf dieser Fall
hat und so und so viele digital-abos
gebracht
Chefredakteure die ihren Redakteuren
Redakteurinnen sagen lass uns bitte mehr
Geschichten dieser Art finden weil das
klickt das verkauft sich das sichert am
Ende auch Arbeitsplätze also das heißt
wir reden dann nicht mehr unbedingt über
die Suche nach Wahrheit sondern wir
reden über einen marktwirtschaftlichen
Mechanismus wir reden über Angebote und
Nachfrage und das hat dann irgendwann
mit Journalismus nicht mehr viel zu tun
wenn es so ist wie Sie es beschreiben
bin ich ihrer Meinung ich glaube also
ich kenne
aus meiner journalistischen langjährigen
Erfahrung kein Fall wo wir jemand gesagt
hätte so eine Geschichte klickt sie zu
dass du sowas kriegst und wenn das nicht
ganz so stimmt aber Hauptsache wären das
raus das habe ich nie erlebt ich habe es
nie erlebt und ich würde aber sie wissen
wie wichtig es ist das ist klickt und
sie wissen unter welchen Druck oder jede
Geschichte logischerweise jede
Geschichte muss löschen was ja es ist
doch ganz klar
die Situation sind wir in einem wir sind
ja auch im Journalismus in einem Wandel
und ich würde noch nicht von Krise
sprechen aber wir werden uns sehr sehr
reformieren müssen und wir werden
natürlich darauf ist doch gar keine
Frage natürlich brauchen wir eine
Qualitätsdebatte und natürlich weiß ich
wenn ich irgendein Text über den
Bundeskanzler schreibe was er da schönes
gemacht und das wird nicht geklickt wird
am Ende mein Job nicht bezahlt also muss
ich mir was überlegen wie ich die
Menschen auf die Seite ziehen kann dass
sie meine Texte lesen
ein Fall wie Rammstein klickt aus ganz
vielen verschiedenen Gründen
werden dann liegt das an der Geschichte
und natürlich gehe ich jetzt da sage ich
erstmal die Unschuldsvermutung gehe ich
für die Zeitung und für die Medien die
darüber berichtet haben natürlich gehe
ich davon aus dass das mit dass das so
abgewogen ist dass Sie genügend Beweise
ihre Ansicht haben dass sie über diese
Geschichte sprechen und ich finde das
was da beschrieben ist was ich gelesen
habe so skandalös dass meiner Ansicht
nach ein hohes Interesse da ist darüber
zu schreiben und sie haben im Fortgang
gesehen von wegen erledigt die Konzerte
waren voll
Rammstein hat gefeierte Konzerte danach
gehabt es sind kleine Gruppen vor das
Olympiastadion in Berlin gezogen und
haben sich für die Frauen eingesetzt und
es ist sowohl Gerd aber ich muss es
sagen eine Gruppe von Fans kam dann und
schrien den rüber bück dich das ist
genau die Wortwahl die die haben hat
mich eigentlich bestätigt das ganz viel
daran ist für mich war das eine sehr
wichtige Berichterstattung wenn die
klickt ist gut daraus ein
Geschäftsmodell zu machen und sagen wir
brauchen so was und deswegen denken wir
unsere Standards ist eine Katastrophe
der da würde ich für die seriösen Medien
sagen
kommt hoffentlich nicht vor und bei den
anderen oder bei einer anderen
Berichterstattung die da Zweifel lässt
bin ich sehr wohl für Konsequenzen klar
wir Journalisten sind absolut
verantwortlich dafür was wir machen und
wenn wir
Biografien vernichten oder Menschen
vernichten ganz klar das muss
Konsequenzen haben und auf der anderen
Seite möchte ich über Frauen lesen und
berichten können deren Existenz schon
vernichtet wurde und die ja in auch eine
macht das ist ja immer das Problem die
müssen sich ja auch trauen können so
etwas
[Musik]
öffentlich
durchgängig verurteilt worden
bei Mockridge ähm man ist nicht
durchgehen verurteilt worden also
zufälligerweise kenne ich diesen Fall
ziemlich gut Kachelmann und Kachelmann
ist bis auf die Zeit eine einzige
Zeitung und da eine einzige Journalistin
von allen über den Kamm Geschehen worden
also das bei Karin Mann stimmt nicht ich
glaube das Problem ist noch ein anderes
wenn ich das sagen darf
umso mehr Fälle
die großen der Öffentlichkeit waren
später in sich zusammenfallen mal
abgesehen von den Leuten die das
zerstört
umso schlechter und umso schädlicher ist
es für die Opfer das dürfen sie auch
nicht vergessen als nächstes kommt
wieder jemand und sagt mir ist das und
das angetan und alle sagen dann auch
kommt das wir wissen ja wie es ausgeht
und das ist nämlich eines der ganz
großen Probleme dass sie gleichzeitig
mit
diesen fehlgegangenen Geschichten auch
die Opfer bestrafen und wenn ich ihn
noch etwas sagen darf
wenn mir irgendetwas zuwider ist und
zwar wirklich schwer zu wieder dann sind
das die Fans von den Rammstein Konzerten
die 20 mal hintereinander vor einer
peniskanone Deutschland brüllen das ist
habe ich also finde ich ganz grauenhaft
aber dass diese Fans zu Leuten die dort
demonstrieren bück dich rufen das als
Beweis oder als Anhalt oder als
irgendetwas zu nehmen dafür was Till
Lindemann oder die Band gemacht hat das
finde ich geht wirklich zu weit und das
haben sie eben gesagt das eine hat mit
dem anderen nicht das Geringste zu tun
ich ja ich sehe da ich sehe das anders
ich ähm ich wenn sie ich
gehen Sie vor andere Konzerte gehen sie
zu Bruce Springsteen da werden sie
anderes hören es ist doch ich gehe doch
zu so einem Konzert und ich bin doch Fan
weil ich lieder wie ich tu dir weh und
so weiter mit Vergewaltigungsfantasien
gerne hören möchte sonst gehe ich da
doch nicht hin aber das hat es mit dem
Vorwürfen
es ist für mich eine
es ging ja darum ob
wem man was vertraut oder in in welche
Berichterstattung man Vertrauen hat ich
habe die Zeitung genannt ich habe für
mich ist das wenn ich seriöse Medien
nehme das ist die Zeitung in der ich aus
der ich meine Informationen oder das wo
ich gelesen habe dann
habe ich das Vertrauen dass das so gut
recherchiert ist dass das stimmt das
habe ich gesagt das ist erstmal das
Thema ist ja über das Verhalten der Fans
immer noch nicht schließen auf das
Verhalten eines Beschuldigten wir hatten
jetzt eine ganz große Bandbreite wir
haben angefangen
über Emotionen wir reden über etwas
Gefühle ist aber wir reden nicht über
hatte
also da würden sie mich falsch verstehen
dass ich das als Beweis für die
KO-Tropfen genommen hat das nicht ich
habe nur versucht zu vermitteln dass
weil ja so ein bisschen in Frage
gestellt wurde ist das nicht ganz weit
hergeholt hat die Frau das vielleicht
erfunden mit den KO-Tropfen wenn sie
innerlich zerrissen ist und das danach
sagt und das vielleicht nicht bewusst
mitgemacht hat sondern weil sie k.o
getroffen hat kann man der überhaupt
glauben das finde ich in bei diesem
Thema auch gewagt auch sehr schwierig
und es passt genau in das Bild das den
Frauen dann eben erst mal wieder nicht
geglaubt wird und der
also es ist jetzt ja nicht in allen
Fällen alles widerlegt also wir sind ja
in vielen Fällen stimmen die Dinge ja
auch und
da zum Grund Misstrauen reinzubringen
dass man das erstmal anzweifeln muss und
wie auch in diesem Fall das finde ich
für die Frauen aussichtslos natürlich
werden sie sich dann nicht mehr an
Medien wenden und natürlich brauchen Sie
Unterstützung also
ich glaube darf ich vielleicht ganz kurz
noch mal dazu etwas sagen es geht
überhaupt nicht darum
das irgendetwas widerlegt ist sondern es
geht um die Frage kann ich es beweisen
das ist etwas vollkommen anderes es geht
auch nicht um ein grundsätzliches
Misstrauen gegen diese
Frau die das in dem Fall mit den
KO-Tropfen behauptet hat ich kenne nicht
Lindemann ich kenne auch nicht die Frau
die das behauptet hat es geht mir
ausschließlich um die Frage was passiert
wenn ich jemanden
öffentlich vor einem Millionenpublikum
für eine
unfassbare harte Straftat bezichtige und
ich kann diese Straftat später nicht
beweisen was ist die Konsequenz daraus
das ist die einzige Frage die Stelle
ich habe ich habe schon Fragen darf um
das zu klären aber deswegen muss man
trotzdem so darüber berichten können
nein man muss eine verdachtsbericht
Erstattung ohne jeden Zweifel machen
können als habe ich ihn auch vorhin
gesagt wenn wir keine
Verdachtsberichterstattung machen können
dann hat die Presse an diesem Punkt
überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr aber ich muss
mir sicher sein an dieser Stelle dass
ich das beweisen kann es ist ja nicht so
das widerspricht sich doch
Entschuldigung verdachtsberichte
Entscheidung beweisen wir haben hier
eine eidesstattliche Versicherung einer
einer jungen Frau da hat das würde ihn
doch reichen sie sind doch selbst
Juristin
nachher gehen Sie zu dem Richter und und
der Richter sagt konntest du das nicht
heute sondern konntest du damals das in
diese Form beweisen und sie sagen ja ich
habe eine alte stadtliche Versicherung
ich habe das durch weitere Zeugen dann
sind sie raus aus der Sache aber genau
das passiert doch nein nein das passiert
gerade nicht das passiert beispielsweise
bei Luke Mockridge ist das nicht
passiert
ja jetzt
gerade gesprochen
der der an dem Punkt haben sie wiederum
recht
die Lindemann wird durch diese Vorwürfe
überhaupt nicht zerstört weil die Fans
so sind ja die kaufen weiter ihre Karte
geführt haben in der Diskussion ist dass
man in Wahrheit zwischen all diesen
Fällen und das war ihre ausgangskrise
wirklich differenzieren muss also man
kann auch diese Fälle nicht sein
also nur das sage ich ich sage ihr nur
und und das ist ausschließlich das was
ich sagen wenn
Verdachtsberichterstattung ich glaube
mal muss unbedingt sein aber ich muss
den Verdacht den ich äußere in dem
Moment in dem ich ihn äußere beweisen
können dass ich in ein halbes Jahr
später nicht mehr bei beweisen kann ist
etwas völlig anderes wenn ich die
entsprechenden alte stadtlichen
Versicherung habe aber die alte
stattliche Versicherung übrigens um das
mal ganz klar zu sagen dieser Frau das
Till Lindemann ihr k.o.-tropfen
verabreicht haben soll und das Till
Lindemann sie vergewaltigt haben soll
die gibt es nicht eine solche ja aber
das ist das Ergebnis
und das hat übrigens das Landgericht
Hamburg auch so gesehen wie diese
Artikel geschrieben worden sind dass
sich in den Köpfen festsetzt und auch
bei ihm er ehrlich gesagt gerade nein
ich habe von der Band gesprochen
wir sind leider leider schon über der
Zeit